[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de ma fenêtre froide et rectangulaire
quand la pluie fait chant c'est l'audeur
de la pierre je vois revenir les saisons
qui mangent les gouttières mais je te
vois pas revenir et j'ai le cœur à
l'envers peut-être te caches-tu dis-moi
comme une brigande de sous les parapluie
qui passe en guirlande comme s'il
dansait dans la rue côté pè ou un un
Chacha en fil indienne un Mambo en fil
de
[Musique]
laineanana mais qu'est-ce que tu peux
faire Rosan banana tu me laisses tout
seul sur la tre Rosan banana si tu
voyais ma misère Rosan banana qu'est-ce
que tu peux bien
faire
c'est dans une île à Coco comme dans les
documentaires là où l'on voit des
heureux qui n'ont que le temps de rien
faire que tu es parti un soir pour un
concours de pé et je t'ai perdu vers le
bar tout au fond d'un vieux
[Musique]
dans
Rosan banana mais qu'est-ce que tu peux
faire Rosan panana tu me laisses tout
seul sur la terre Rosan banana si tu
voyais ma misère Rosan banana qu'est-ce
que tu peux bien
[Musique]
faire
panana Ros
panana Rosan banana mais qu'est-ce que
tu peux faire Rosan banana tu me laisses
tout seul sur la terre Rosan banana si
tu voyais ma misère Rosana banana mais
qu'est-ce que tu peux
[Musique]
faireanana mais qu'est-ce que tu peux
faire banana tu me laisses tout seul sur
la terre Rosana banana si tu voyais ma
misère Rosana banana qu'est-ce que tu
peux bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faire